You guys got to check this out.
>> I don't know about nobody else, but I
can tell you we know we was doing with
Triple 6. Hey, we exactly know what it
meant. I hated God for what he did. But
as it came to the Triple 6, I didn't
want I don't think I hate him that much,
but I did it because it was money. I
even had the Satanic books, the little
warlock materials, you know, every
warlock got to have a dagger, cut the
little punch stars, whatever, little
candles and I was into it. Something
about the other Bible didn't work out.
Some folks were scared of it and left.
put it like that. But me, I meant what I
was saying. I definitely meant it. I'mma
make black folks comfortable with Triple
6. I read a lot and I put all that into
the music. You get what I'm saying? Cuz
how you get Satan's name going, you get
the kids to like it. So, I think I was
used by Satan and I think he's a I meant
what I was saying. You know, I really
meant it. I was a clean, fancy type
Satanist. How many songs have you heard
that say do what you want to do or
follow your heart, right? It's always
about do what thou wilt. Satanism is all
about self, worship of self, and doing
what you want to do and not what God has
for your life. This makes me remember
Pastor Craig Lewis's presentation called
The Truth Behind Hip Hop on X Ministries
when he said he actually heard a word
from God saying that Satanism was going
to get in rap music. And at the time, he
said, "Man, the brothers aren't with
this. I'm not going to get into the
satanic stuff. But then next thing he
knows, he saw it happen.
>> Holy Spirit came to me a little little
while after that and said, uh, the devil
is not satisfied with this because he
didn't really say it like this, but I'm
going to say it so y'all can understand
it. The brothers ain't down with heavy
metal. That form of music that he was
forming was what we know as the hip-hop
culture. And at the time, it seemed a
little unbelievable because God began to
tell me how the black youth would begin
to actually worship the devil. And I'll
never forget, I guess around 1993, maybe
1992, 1993, I'll never forget. I
remember, you know, I was flipping
through the channels and there was this
cable channel called The Box. Y'all
remember that? There was a video that
popped on. It was by a group called
Almighty RSO. Brother turns around and
in the back of his flattop, he had 666
cut in his head. A brother. Now, that
that scared me cuz you know, we don't
play with the devil like that. I said,
"Oh my goodness." The Holy Spirit spoke
to me and said, "Craig, get ready."
>> Pastor Craig Lewis said the Holy Spirit
told him before 1993 that rap music was
going to start having satanic elements
in there. And in 1993, he saw that when
somebody turned around and had 666 in
their flattop. Here we are in the day
and age where pop music, country music,
rap music, metal music, they all have
these satanic themes in them. And we're
in a time period where Satan doesn't
even have to hide anymore. And
Christians are still making excuses to
keep on listening to this secular music.